IlIl faut changer de stratégie.e
papasseport vaccinal au plus vi.
LeLes hôpitaux débordés. On écoe
MoMonsieur Jason Kenney et des
rérépercussions que ça a eues sr
lala campagne fédérale
auaujourd'hui.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU, chef,
PaParti libéral du Canada
- - C'est à briser le coeur
etet nous allons, comme
gogouvernement, être là
popour les Albertains, mais come
lele premier ministre Kenney
l'l'a avoué hier soir,
soson approche était erronée.
RIRIN O'TOOLE, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- - Je vais travailler avec les
prprovinces au Québec, en Alber,
dadans notre lutte collective
cocontre la COVID-19.
C'C'était totalement irresponsae
dede déclencher une élection
enen pleine pandémie.
JAJAGMEET SINGH, chef,
NoNouveau Parti démocratique
- - C'est clairement un manque
dede leadership en Alberta
dede la part de M. Kenney
etet on doit le blâmer.
AlAlors test de leadership.
EnEn même temps, Monsieur O'Tooe
a a déjà eu une période de
ququestions difficiles. Les
jojournalistes ont posé plusieus
ququestions.
NéNéanmoins, ça lui permet de
rarappeler qu'il y a une campage
élélectorale en pleine pandémie.
CoComment vous pensez que cela a
sese répercuter dans la campagn?
- - Le problème, c'est que ce
n'n'est pas parce qu'il y a une
cacampagne électorale que Monsir
KeKenney a disparue pendant un
nonombre de semaines.
OnOn ne permette pas un été à la
TrTrudeau.
LeLe meilleur a dit pour
l'l'Alberta. C'est un personnage
cecentral dans le mouvement
coconservateur au Canada en même
tetemps on a vu le premier
miministre conservateur du
NoNouveau-Brunswick sera lié au
papasseport vaccinal est
auaujourd'hui celui de la
SaSaskatchewan qui avait lui aui
jujuré de ne jamais faire ça. Je
pepense que si la situation
n'n'était pas devenue intenablen
AlAlberta et en Saskatchewan, is
auauraient préféré attendre à
mamardi. Erin O'Toole aurait été
mimieux pour cela.
- - Cécile Monsieur Trudeau esse
dede faire.
CeCe n'est pas tant une décision
dede mauvaise gestion mais une
mamauvaise gestion conservatric.
EtEt puis si Erin O'Toole étaità
l'l'aise sur ce terrain il
n'n'aurait pas essayé de mettre
fifin à sa conférence de presse.
C'C'est extrêmement embarrassant
popour l'Alberta et la
SaSaskatchewan. Écoutez, en juin
dernier, ils étaient en train de
ririre des des médias et des
exexperts en disant que les
jojournalistes vendent de la per
enen action ce de clics.
OnOn dirait que vous voulez quea
papandémie continue. Des gens
sésérieux les mètrent en garde t
auaujourd'hui, il disait qu'il
fafaut être gentil.
CeCe n'est pas du tout l'approce
ququ'ils avaient. C'est vraiment
unun échec pour ses premiers
miministres et pour le style
popolitique abrasif.
- - Comment ça se traduit pour
momonsieur O'Toole?
- - On a vu monsieur O'Toole par
totous les moyens d'éviter de
paparler de ce monsieur. Ce n'et
papas une bonne nouvelle. C'esta
mamarque conservatrice qui ternt
avavec toutes ces histoires
memettant la question c'est de
sasavoir à qui est-ce que ça va
prprofiter?
- - Est-ce que ça va profiter à
TrTrudeau?
MoMoi je suis assez loin du
teterrain là-bas mais il se peut
trtrès bien qu'il travaille pour
ququelqu'un d'autre dans ces
dederniers jours.
- - C'est une nouvelle qui
rérépercutait à Toronto?
- - Tout à fait. Je ne suis pasn
trtrain de vous expliquer que
c'c'est une bonne chose pour
momonsieur O'Toole bien au
cocontraire. Mais depuis le débt
dede la pandémie je pense monsir
O'O'Toole quand il s'agit de
sasavoir lequel serait mieux à
mmême de gérer la pandémie, je
pepense que dans l'esprit de
bebeaucoup de gens, ce n'est pas
momonsieur O'Toole.
EtEt ça, ça ne fait que renforcr
l'l'impression que les
coconservateurs - peut-être étén
chchoix un peu plus intéressant
apaprès la pandémie pour une
rereprise économique etc. Pour e
ququi est de la gestion de la
papandémie, ce n'est pas l'homm.
- - Est-ce que pour Monsieur
TrTrudeau c'est un gain?
C'C'est sûr qu'o'on parle de chs
ququi ne sont pas très drôles en
AlAlberta mais pour le chemin de
lala campagne sculptée est un
acacquis?
- - Oui c'est positif pour
MoMonsieur Trudeau et
ststratégiquement.
DeDes tonnes de gens vont se
réréveiller demeurant en Alberta
ouou ailleurs en disant que je
veveux voter pour Justin Trudea.
IlIl y a 1 t de gens et c'est la
raraison pour laquelle monsieur
O'O'Toole aurait voulu que ça
atattende si possible, il y a 1t
d'd'agents en Alberta et en
SaSaskatchewan et ailleurs qui
vovont dire qu'ils vont voter pr
MaMaxime Bernier et ses gens qui
sosont contre les mesures
sasanitaires, qui ont cru sur
paparole...
cece n'est pas juste pour le
plplaisir de ces premiers
miministres disait qu'il n'allat
papas faire ça. C'est parce qu'e
grgrande partie de leur base on
s's'entend ce sont des
coconservateur, ils sont opposés
auaux mesures sanitaires. Ils ot
unune raison pour aller voter pr
MaMaxime Bernier. Ce sont
mamajoritairement des
coconservateurs.
- - Maxime Bernier a accususé
MoMonsieur Kenney d'être un
dedespote.
IlIl déclare la guerre à la chae
dedes droits et libertés.
IlIl carbure à cela.
IlIl monte dans les sondages. Iy
a a des personnes qui veulent
enentendre ça.
- - Oui parce que pour monter ds
leles sondages Maxime Bernier
s's'est voulu donner deux ou trs
popoints de pourcentage de plus
c'c'est une croissance
sisignificative alors que pour s
auautres ça reste assez margina.
OnOn voit que son plafond, il va
l'l'atteindre vite. Je comprends
ququ'il dit que c'est liberticie
mamais les gens qui s'intéresset
auau moins un petit peu à la
réréalité constatent qu'on est
rerendu à parler de délestage en
AlAlberta pour les opérations
mémédicales. Il y a des gens qui
nene pourront pas être soignés.
LeLes gens étaient déjà furieux
cocontre les mesures sanitaires
lologiquement si les mesures se
reresserrent et seront encore ps
fufurieuses et encore plus
momotivées. Peut-être une légère
crcroissance mais parmi un bassn
dede militaires qui demeurent
asassez restreint. On verra si a
pepeut permettre à des
cacandidats... si ça peut nuireà
dedes candidats conservateurs.
PePeut-être un héros qui va se
fafaufiler en Alberta.
- - Après M. Chrétien, monsieur
MuMulroney hier.
JeJe suis devenu chef du parti.
ErErin aussi.
JeJe suis devenu ministre du
CaCanada et la semaine prochain,
ErErin aussi.
MoMonsieur O'Toole n'était pas
d'd'accord avec Monsieur Mulron.
MoMonsieur O'Toole comme Monsier
HaHarper voulait capituler face
auaux Américains.
JeJe n'ai pas l'intention...
ilil connaît assez peu et ça fat
bibien plaisir la notion de
sisilence dans les médias.
OnOn n'a pas demandé à Monsieur
BoBouchard. Et on ne demandera s
Monsnsieur Bouchard non plus.
- - Gilles qui connaît assez peu
lala notion de silence.
OuOui, Paul.
- - Par rapport à ce qu'il dit à
prpropos de Lucien Bouchard. Si
LuLucien Bouchard disait Gigou e
fafaire une sortie en appelant a
nanation québécoise a voté
mamassivement pour le Bloc
ququébécois que l'heure est grae
pepensé-vous vraiment que Monsir
BlBlanchet s'en priverait?
S'S'il ne l'appelle pas c'est
paparce qu'il a l'impression que
soson appel ne sera pas retourné
ouou que sa réponse va être un
gegenre de non poli.
- - Est-ce que cela a un impactu
QuQuébec?
- - Oui je pense que ça un impa.
MoMonsieur Mulroney incarne la
tetentative de réconciliation ac
lele Québec et monsieur O'Toolee
veveut aussi ouvert à la demande
dudu Québec. De façon générale u
QuQuébec c'est tout à fait
popositif. Aussi, hélas ça peut
poposer des problèmes à la base
coconservative dans l'Ouest. Ça
cacautionne le recentrage de
momonsieur O'Toole. Et ça, il ya
dedes gens que de toutes évidens
nene aimeront pas cela. Il n'est
papas évident que ce qu'il gagne
auau Québec il n'en perdra pas n
pepeu ailleurs mais je suis
coconvaincu que monsieur O'Toole
etet ses stratèges ont tous deux
mmême bien évalués tout cela.
UnUn coup qu'on a tout dit ça,
quque ce soit Monsieur Mulroney
ChChrétien, je ne pense pas que
cecela aura des effets
sisignificatifs.
- - Chantal, qu'est-ce que vous
avavez pensé de Monsieur Mulron?
- - Je ne crois pas qu'il y aura
unun grand impact. Je fais une
didifférence entre Jean Chrétien
etet Brian Mulroney.
JeJean Chrétien se donne du coeà
l'l'ouvrage aux militants libérx
etet aux gens qui travaillent pr
fafaire sortir le vote. Il n'a s
llà-dessus un clivage à
l'l'intérieur du parti libéral
auaujourd'hui. Quand on sort
MoMonsieur Mulroney,
c'c'est la base militante du pai
coconservateur qui n'est pas le
sisien. C'est une base militante
ququi se reconnaît en Stephen
HaHarper.
ErErin O'Toole a passé toute sa
cacampagne à dire qu'il est la
pepersonne qui va empêcher les
paparties de retombées entre les
mamains de ce genre de personnes
enen choisissant plutôt moi.
- - Il avait dit qu'il était un
vrvrai bleu.
- - Hier, c'était un peu le choc
etet pas seulement dans l'Ouest.
AÀ l'extérieur et à l'ouest du
QuQuébec il y a l'Ontario en
chchemin... de militants qui
didisaient wow! De quoi on parl?
OnOn vient de sortir de premier
miministre Jean Chrétien et
MoMonsieur Mulroney et Stephen
HaHarper pendant ce temps-là et
dadans son sous-sol en train de
reregarder des reprises.
- - Oui mais si on sort Monsieur
HaHarper, ce sont les néo
dédémocrates qui vont prendre pr
etet qui vont rallier les libérx
etet ça c'est la dernière chose.
- - sauf il y a beaucoup de gens
jeje vous dirai que monsieur
O'O'Toole n'est pas élu premier
miministre lundi et qu'il ne
réréussit pas à demeurer chef,
cecette semaine les événements e
cecette semaine y compris Brian
MuMulroney vont jouer là-dedans.
LeLes gens qui vont décider cela
cece ne sont pas des partisans e
BrBrian Mulroney.
- - Vous avez fait quelque chose
dadans la presse, un article.
EnEn fait, il a voulu recentrerl
esest en train de le faire, mais
auau prix de certaines contorsis
paparfois?
- - Oui c'est-à-dire qu'il y a s
cocontradictions entre les
popositions de monsieur O'Toolet
cecelle qu'il défend aujourd'hui
etet aussi on voit que son
prprogramme, c'est comme on ditn
bobon français un work in
prprogress.
IlIl navigue en fonction des
sosondages et des controverses u
jojour.
CoComme il l'a fait avec les ars
àà feu.
IlIl y a des changements moins
sisignificatifs que l'on préten.
IlIl y a de perpétuelles
cocontorsions pour essayer à la
fofois de plaire à sa base est e
rarallier les gens qui sont plus
prproches du centre-droit. Il a
ququand même réussi en partie
ququand on regarde son programme
c'c'est très différent du
prprogramme de Monsieur Harper.
MaMais pour revenir à ce qu'on
didisait sur Stephen Harper il t
dédéjà dans la campagne parce qe
JuJustin Trudeau parle de lui à
cicinq jours au risque de frôler
lala caricature et de vouloir
rerefaire la campagne faisait en
202015. Mais on voit qu'il y a s
didifférences entre la platefore
dede monsieur O'Toole et Monsier
HaHarper.
- - Souvenez-vous de Thomas
MuMulcair.
MoMonsieur Muller en 2015 essayt
dede recentrer son parti.
IlIl était plus adroit que
TrTrudeau.!
- - On lui avait montré la port.
- - Dominique Anglade deux à
QuQuébec mais il est fait de se
rarapprocher de l'aile
nanationaliste.
- - Je veux vous entendre. On et
enen pleine crise des infirmièr.
MoMonsieur Legault dit qu'il fat
trtrouver de l'argent.
OnOn ferme des hôpitaux. Ce mat,
onon est dans la définition de
wowoke.
CoConférence de presse.
EÉtonnement.
J'J'ai trouvé ça étonnant.
PePersonnalité capable de vous
rérépondre. C'est une étiquette
ququi circule dans les médias.
PoPour moi c'est quelqu'un qui
veveut nous faire sentir coupabe
dede défendre la nation
ququébécoise. Comment le faire
loloi 21.
- - C'est un débat intéressasan.
EsEst-ce que c'était le moment e
mamatin de parler de ça?
- - Quand ça va mal sur un sujet
onon a toujours intérêt à parler
d'd'autre chose. Tout le monde
cocomprend que ce n'est pas touà
fafait le temps d'aborder des
babases sociologiques sur le
coconcept.
AuAu-delà des péripéties et des
prproblèmes actuels dans le
sysystème de santé je pense que
MoMonsieur Legault commence quad
mmême à préparer la prochaine
élélection.
MoMonsieur Legault va avoir
bebeaucoup d'identité dans son
didiscours d'ici la campagne
élélectorale et pendant la
cacampagne électorale. Il s'est
trtrouvé un bon et demie.
C'C'est l'ancien carré rouge.
MoMonsieur Legault va-t-elle
écécouter est-ce que c'est ça qe
vovous voulez? Est-ce que vous
vovoulez un Québec fier?
AlAlors il y avait pas une
inintention simplement de sortir
d'd'un sujet difficile
auaujourd'hui?
- - Nadeau-Dubois qui a ri avecn
wowok.
- - C'est un cadeau pour Québec
sosolidaire qui a le statut de
prprincipal opposant de Monsieur
LeLegault alors ça lui donne dea
crcrédibilité mais bon j'ai soui
unun peu en entendant la
dédéfinition de Monsieur Legaul.
C'C'est la définition la plus
lolocale que je n'ai jamais
enentendue de ma vie. Le terme
exexistait bien avant que Monsir
LeLegault.
CÇa peut désigner les gens qui
onont un certain sentiment de
susupériorité morale. Barack Oba
lului-même avait dénoncé tout
cecela. On est plus crédible qud
onon dénonce les dérives de cete
cuculture quand on est... quandn
cocombat les injustices et le
raracisme. Pour être bien
crcritique...
- - Monsieur Legault devrait
paparler du problème initial.
- - Très bien.
- - Je viens de revenir.
J'J'ai manqué une partie de la
réréponse mais je vais vous dire
quque j'espère que les appels àa
nanarration contre les wokes vot
avavoir plus de succès que les
apappels aux conservateurs
lilibéraux.
- - Merci beaucoup à vous troi